[Music]
like sneaky is insanely good and he just
spent like criminally underrated for
pretty much his whole career let's be
honest me sneaky and spender the best ad
carry's in the region sneaky and lame
well that guy was a godless in danger he
92b to a play in the bot lane say yes
everything for supporting me here
thought 9 all these years you guys have
been really kind to me appreciate about
before he was an LCS legend sneaky
bounced around a couple amateur teams
trolling people in his spare time what
is he looking at he's confused taste
irks stupid he eventually found his way
to Quantic a mning which was the roster
that eventually became cloud 9 video
blog
a sneaky cast are doing nothing over
here that meteos just being a baller
have balls and then lemon they looked
more like a group of friends than they
did a team of competitors I got a lot of
stuff nostalgia when I hang out with you
know media sore balls lemon I like those
guys like we talked about the good times
from before cuz there's so much funny
stuff that happened for us that we can
just remember together back then
sneaky was not the ad carry superstar we
know today
he was basically an engaged bot only one
dragon for cloud 9 they get narrow
though and there's no flash off after
cloud 9 they throw down the traps that
get the kills instantly between high
shock calling meteos as farm heavy
jungling and Balls's top lane
destruction well sneaky took on more of
a supportive role while the other
original members left sneaky stayed
transitioning from his supportive role
to one of cloud nines biggest threats
and the face of the team pretty weird
only it was
cloud9 medius is like coming John a few
times I came and came and went few times
yeah it feels weird being the original
member and hope you keep it that way now
fans don't just love sneaky for his
in-game prowess because in addition to
being an accomplished pro he's one of
Twitch's biggest league streamers it's
always really fun for me um every time I
go into streaming I'm just there for
like the enjoyment I'm playing the game
dude because I love it and then also
streaming it's just tons of fun
interacting with them like every time I
read the chat there's always something
funny and the guy further expanded the
sneaky Empire with a hobby that he's
well shockingly good at what started out
as sneaky just wearing clothes that fan
sent him eventually turned into a
booming side business his patreon has
over 1400 subscribers I think it
definitely brings in a whole new
audience for sure it's pretty well
received among even the people that
we're currently following me
maybe it's turn some people away but it
definitely brought in a whole lot more
I've been I've been gaining followers as
its gone on despite his constant
streaming and cause playing sneaky
stayed at the top of na he always
somehow ended up as the last hope of an
A in 2018 sneaky and cloud 9 made
world's history accomplishing something
no other na team has done since season 1
semi-finals good [ __ ]
nice we did it
made us enemies boys how are you boys
oh yeah we're not going [ __ ] home
despite some bumps in the road c9 and
sneaky seemed like the perfect eSports
duo well that is until this offseason
the team would play sneaky with TSM's ad
carry's vent which was the most
controversial move in the NA offseason
getting rid of sneaky is like the
biggest mistake they can make because
this dude is like insanely good he will
handle any situation give him if you
give him resources he will hard carry if
you put him in the worst situation
possible he'll make the best out of it
like sneaky is insanely good and he just
really criminally underrated for pretty
much his whole career and shirts
Sneaky's 2019 wasn't his best season but
wasn't great for Sven either a fight
that goes the right way will push people
down the question is can they find those
margins can they find that opening so
far TSM has outmaneuvered and this puts
sneaky in a tough spot because while he
lost his starting position he was still
signed with the team through 2021 I
think it's a virus but I won't be
playing 49 and I'm not gonna get a test
report I would not feel right in that
situation because then it feels like I'm
trying to fight back my spot against
people that didn't want me to be there
or with people that didn't want me to be
there and after this van announcement
well the community went nuts fans
couldn't stop speculating we're sneaky
would land next what do you reunite with
meteos on a hundred thieves would he
join up with aphromoo & froggin on
Dignitas but the trade window came and
went and none of these predictions came
true
instead sneaky made one of the hardest
decisions of his career
what's next I'll be streaming as an
independent pretty much not under the c9
flag
I'll be able to explore opportunities hi
ma'am I will be moving into an adviser
role for c9 for sneaky this is goodbye
for now but maybe not forever the dude
is still one of the better ad carry's in
na and well he hasn't officially retired
yet I think sneaky is good and yeah
that year I think he might have too much
pride to admit that he had a bad year
that doesn't mean he's bad that doesn't
mean he's washed up doesn't mean
anything it just means you can just have
a bad experience for a short period of
time he's been good for like seven years
in a row
pretty much so I don't think it's I
don't think it's a big deal that he
didn't have his best year in season nine
but like I think it's crazy that the way
they're treating him and whether he
makes his pro come back or remains a
full-time streamer sneaky has built a
legacy as one of the greatest players
that na has ever produced and that can
never be taken away thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up art Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
you